le continent il n'est pas surpeuplée
bien qu'on soit un milliard deux de
l'individu actuel mandat celle qui a la
plus faible densité du monde et donc son
rôle dans sa progression et qu'on ne la
raconte pas ça à ça sa superficie
sa géographie et qu'on la lit dans le
temps effectivement elle peut inquiéter
certains mais aujourd'hui on est juste
en train de le couvrir en fait je dirais
une démographie qu'il a perdu ses
derniers siècles
et là aussi le sco que le démographe et
et qu'on a réfléchi pas d'un point de
vue continental et géographique et
commence à la démographie du monde c'est
là où lequel il va devoir est
intéressant syndicaux envisagent que
comme paint ball que d'anjou des gens du
monde y est drôle d'individu qui laisse
si nous avions une circulation et une
mobilité les flux s'équilibrer dans la
géographie du monde
mais si on continue à penser chinois au
le père africain ils sont et qu'ils sont
trop peu nombreux ne sont pas assez on
est encore dans une dans un imaginaire
du clan et c est ça la grande question
jeudi
effectivement il ya moins de l'opérer il
y aura 4 % d'européens en 2005 et 42%
asiatique et que les 40% africain nous
allons encore dans des catégories de la
géographie de la nation de la race qui
fait que nous nous vivons pas company
idées qui pourraient se répartir de
manière équilibrée sur la surface du
globe
et si on envisage la question comme ça
n'a aucune démographie mais un problème
en soi si on lui en place les
infrastructures sociales sanitaires le
cadre depuis ces 15 m appelle des
facteurs de conversion que les individus
plus vive
voilà donc deux manières bing et qui est
équité territoriale globale et moniales
dont j'ai le sentiment qu'on a toujours
une échelle qui n'est pas la bonne
échelle accueil nous envisageons les
choses ils sont toujours prisonniers
deux catégories qui vérifient des
données qui sont des données je dirais
contingenté historique
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de me dire
est ce que la population du globe dans
un siècle aura assez de ressources pour
asma pacte il est ce que nous sommes en
mesure de répondre aux besoins de la
population du globe plus que elle sera
plus d'africains que de chinois ou de
l'opéra
[Musique]